on these exchanges quite predictable
they've been well rehearsed before we
took place I do think the Prime Minister
with the greatest respect has a
tremendous skill in keeping a straight
face while she's being so disingenuous
[Applause]
the package the fact is he's now
desperate to have an election in order
to bring this houses proceedings to an
end and to have the general election
clearly before October the 31st and he's
obviously going to campaign before that
on the basis that he's been thwarted in
getting an amazing beneficial deal of
this country which is actually being
blocked by wicked continental
politicians politicians and the em
pieces the House of Commons you have no
sense of the true national interest
which is to keep him in power it's wrong
to say that the opposition to him is
trying to reverse the referendum a very
large percentage of those who've been
defeating him in the last two days are
prepared to vote for brexit they voted
for brexit more often than he has he
cause delay in marks and the gorse delay
in a problem we wish to do so on
satisfaction reasonable terms we now
have a bill which is the beginning of a
pathway to actually give us more time
for grown-up sensible diplomatic
exchanges between others the idea that
on the European the European Union that
their refusal as a deal there because
they really think they're going to trap
us in permanently is nonsense they're
desperate to get a deal but they of
course they're desperate to get a deal
but not so desperate that they're going
to accept terms which will cause chaos
in Northern Ireland politically and
economically and will shatter the normal
rules which hold together the single
market in the customs union upon which
their base